blasenberg the festival reduced this
year after a two-year break the pandemic
has put on hold lives of millions of
people around the world but has not
broke
we in ukraine would also like to live
the life as we used to and enjoy freedom
and this wonderful summer but we cannot
do that because the most terrible has
happened
russia has stolen our peace
but
we will not let russia's war break us
and we will want to stop the war before
it ruins people's lives in other
countries of europe africa asia latin
america
they are all under threat now
that is why i turn to you for support
glastonbury is the greatest
concentration of freedom these days and
i ask you to share this feeling with
everyone whose freedom is under attack
spread the truth about russia's war help
ukrainians who are forced to flee their
homes because of the war
find our united 24 charity platform and
put pressure on all the politicians you
know to help restore peace in ukraine
time is priceless and every day is
measured in human lives
the more people join us in defending
freedom and truth
the sooner russia's war against ukraine
will end
prove that freedom always wins thank you
slavokraine
[Applause]
you